what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so never in a million years would I
believed we'd have a reason to make a
video about Valkyrie I had no reason
ever to believe that she would actually
get any measure of screen time but I'm
glad she is because Valkyrie is really
one of the more interesting characters
and Marvel she could be really confusing
me but she's really intriguing in terms
of her role in the Marvel Pantheon and
how she exists and so on and so forth so
when it comes to the Valkyrie concept
there is a lot of confusion among people
who were not familiar with her character
in the sense that there's the Valkyrie
as a idea as a concept of sorts and then
there's the Valkyrie character the first
appearance of Valkyrie quote-unquote was
the concept it actually came out and
Avengers number 83 back in 1970 I think
it was and it was written by Roy Thomas
now remember with Roy Thomas writing The
Avengers between issues 35 and 104 I
believe it was all about experimentation
it was all about trying new things
seeing what worked in a lot of ways his
experimentation with the Avengers set
the stage for Chris Claremont
experimentation with the x-men but
regardless the whole idea was that
Valkyries debut basically came with the
actions of a character called a more of
The Enchantress now we didn't initially
know about this instead the Valkyrie
character just kind of popped up in
really more of a two-part story with
issues 82 and 83 the bulk of it was in
83 but it was basically a two-part story
that featured the introduction and the
creation of a concept called the Lady
liberators now the lady liberators was
Roy Thomas's attempt to roll in female
readers in the sense that the Valkyrie
persona as it showed up was basically
like all men everywhere bad they're
chauvinist and they have to go away it
was interesting in terms of how it
happened but when it came to comic books
back in the 1950s 1960s even going all
the way back to like the 30s and 40s
there was really just like two separate
markets you basically had like the
romance market you know young stories
about people being in love and things
like that that's where a lot of the
girls resided and then you had
superheroes and that's where a lot of
the boys resided and the result was that
when the superhero genre really began to
experience this second Renaissance from
the mid 1950s with the introduction of
Barry Allen and Marvel's explosion of
popularity in the early 1960s the idea
was to grab those female readers who
never would have really had a reason to
read superhero comics and bring them in
and the lady liberators serve that
purpose because it was essentially this
Valkyrie character bringing together
Janet Van Dyne the why
of Hank Pym The Scarlet Witch Medusa of
the Inhumans in natasha romanoff The
Black Widow
the problem with this is that if you
didn't read Marvel you didn't really
know who these characters were and so
the introduction in and of itself
alienated a lot of potential female
readers because they picked up the story
and felt totally lost because it was
assumed they already knew who these
characters were and so the story as it
unfolds is it basically deals with this
idea of Valkyrie giving her origin in
the sense that she was basically a lab
assistant for a person named dr. Erwin
and dr. Erwin was depicted as this guy
who is extremely chauvinist basically
saying I don't need a woman to help me
you know if I need a secretary I'll get
ahold of you but until then just get out
of here and go do your thing
following this it unfolded much in the
same way is like Jay Garrick the Flash's
origin the flash Jay Garrick was a kid
who was basically working with deuterium
with heavy water you know in this
instance it is this woman you know
Valkyrie working with chemicals she's
trying to figure out what's going on
eventually she just passes out from
exhaustion Jay Garrick passed out from
exhaustion they end up waking up after
being exposed to these fumes Jay Garrick
can run at the speed of thought and
Valkyrie has powers their origin stories
are almost completely identical but
regardless the scenario basically
unfolded with Valkyrie realizing she had
these abilities and in turn that came to
the belief that men everywhere were bad
what it did is it led to her rallying up
these various female leads from the
existing Marvel superhero stories and
then taking them to basically battle the
Avengers now the arrival of the Avengers
is kind of interesting it's basically a
costume contest that's going on in
Rutland Vermont which is kind of kind of
funny here but the Avengers showing up
is just the idea that they were
basically lured here under false
pretenses it eventually leads to them
taking part in the parade you know for
Halloween and so on and so forth but
they're also met with the Masters of
evil because you know they're the
Masters of evil whatever and so
ultimately things unfold with this bit
of a skirmish between the Avengers the
Masters of evil then the Lady liberators
arrive and this basically results in a
explanation of sorts it results in the
truth coming to light in the sense that
the lady liberators led by Valkyrie are
actually able to overpower their you
know the other superheroes who were
there and then in turn we end up finding
out that what the Masters of evil were
after was a device that had been
constructed by dr. Edwin it was
essentially this device that was
referred to as the parallel time
projector and what he would do is it
would allow a person to access alternate
realities and so this was ultimately
what the lady liberators led by Valkyrie
we're pursuing not only that we actually
end up finding out that this is not
Valkyrie instead this is a person called
Amora The Enchantress and this is where
the confusion of the origin story begins
to come into play with regards to or
more of the Enchantress she was actually
some girl who was just born in Asgard
somewhere and then eventually was
trained under the norms who were
basically these super powerful witches
of sorts that exist in as you go I
proper ultimately it led to a more being
booted just because of the fact that she
just refused to accept any measure of
discipline and then from there she just
charmed various people who were adept
and sorcery and magic and so on and so
forth using her abilities to effectively
enslave guys and then in turn bolster
her own powers and so from there there
was a point whereby she was kicked out
of Asgard alongside executioner which is
one of the characters that you're gonna
see in thor ragnarok and alongside
enchantress he helped her alongside a
multitude of her campaigns but because
the fact that she was literally trying
to seize Asgard from Odin she was booted
out this led to them being banished to a
different realm and then eventually
executioner left her and went to another
queen and then that goes into the origin
story of the defender so keep that in
the back of your mind for a second but
the whole idea here is that because of
the fact that in chant Rose is just this
chick who was essentially heartbroken by
the fact that you know executioner left
her hanging and was able to defy her
senses means that she's now just on this
quest to seize control of Asgard and
just sort of rule everything and of
course once everybody realizes what's
going on
Tasha Romanoff and Black Widow Janov and
on which they basically overpower her
and she's just sent to another dimension
and that's really about it now the whole
idea of the Valkyrie character which is
to say the topic of this particular
video this really came out of a of
several pre lewd stories with Roy Thomas
writing The Avengers the goal of Marvel
was to basically bolster their comics in
any conceivable way that they possibly
could I mean if they could spin-off new
x-men titles they would spin-off new
x-men titles so they could spit off more
spider-man titles they would spin-off
more spider-man titles it was the idea
make as many comics as we can
conceivably get away with without
breaking our budget and then see if they
sell if they don't sell we'll cancel
them but you miss 100% of the shots you
don't take
so we might as well just throw them out
there anyway and so what ended up
happening is in the respective series of
name with a submariner Doctor Strange
and The Incredible Hulk it was basically
laying the groundwork for the creation
of the defender
and the defenders not to sound crass
were basically a poor man's Avengers
that's really all they were it was just
kind of a small-time spin-off version of
The Avengers but it was a superhero team
unto itself in the sense that instead of
focusing on planetary threats or like
invasions by Loki or different things
like that dr. Strange's defenders team
would face off against mystical threats
and it was actually pretty cool in terms
of how it came together but the fact
remains when it came to the defenders
comic itself really it was a story that
began in the solo series of name worthy
Incredible Hulk of what was left of
Doctor Strange and finished out in
issues one through three of defenders
followed by issue number four seeing the
actual introduction of Valkyrie now this
also saw the introduction of a character
named Barbara Knorr who in a lot of ways
was the Donald Blake of the Thor
personality will talk about those
comparisons here in a second but Barbara
Norris was a character who was
introduced when Steve Englehart
initially launched the defenders line
owing to the fact that writer Roy Thomas
had been promoted to editor in chief and
the idea was that Barbara Norris was
basically just part of a cult that
belonged to a group called the undying
once the sword up race of monster like
creatures who had inhabited the earth at
one point rule the planet and then
ultimately escaped to another dimension
during their the war of the Elder Gods
and different things like that but the
overall gist of this was that Barbara
Norris alongside her husband Jack Norris
had sought to see the return of the
undying ones now in the individual
stories really incredible hulk 125 and
126 it's expanded on the idea that
barbara Norris had effectively been
tricked into joining this quote by her
mom but the fact remains here that with
this particular character she was this
person who effectively turned coded in
the sense that once she realized how bad
an invasion of the undying ones would be
how much it would destroy all things in
existence she ultimately turned against
the undying ones and tried to keep them
confined this coincided with the
official launch of the defenders and the
arrival of nameless Submariner The
Incredible Hulk and Doctor Strange and
so in this instance it basically led to
this wholesale defeat of the undying
ones but someone had to remain behind
and be this sort of gatekeeper that
would ensure they couldn't escape their
dimension which barbara norris
volunteered to do the problem is that by
the time issue number 3 came about and
it led to the defenders returning to try
to rescue barbara norris and effectively
allow dr. strange to use his magic to
keep the undying once banished to the
around forever we ended up finding out
some pretty seedy things happen behind
the
seems in the sense that Barbara Norris
is basically forced to mate with the
nameless one the leader of the undying
ones the result was that it led to her
effectively losing her mind now this led
directly into issue number four and the
intention of Steve Englehart introducing
the idea of the of the Valkyrie concept
and what we ended up learning is that in
addition to the defenders off doing
their own thing in the background we
also had a more The Enchantress who had
already escaped following the events of
Avengers number 83 coming back in
several instances and continuing her
campaign to in seize control of Asgard
this led her to come across a character
named Black Knight who really isn't
relevant I mean he's an Avenger but he's
not that popular model tried to bring
him back during all-new all-different
marvel and it didn't work nobody read
about his comic most people didn't even
know he was there but the whole idea was
that with the character of Black Knight
alongside Amora The Enchantress they had
basically come across and been whisked
away to the realm of a woman named
Cassie Alaina Nicassio Lena just
harbored this vendetta against a more
The Enchantress because you know she was
accidentally misidentified as amaura and
then banished from Asgard so it was just
hey you got me kicked out of Asgard and
now I hate you that's basically what it
is
this led into you know essentially a
more being captured the fact that her
magic was effectively suppressed by
Cassie Elena and ultimately with the
arrival of Barbra Norris here alongside
the defenders it offered the opportunity
for more to make her escape now in truth
there were a litany of ways that a mork
of a more possibly could have gotten out
her she could have just waited for the
defenders to engineer their own escape
but Steve Englehart wanted to introduce
the concept of Valkyrie because of the
fact the letters pages which is to say
the letters that fans write in to Marvel
Comics were so overwhelmingly supportive
of a Valkyrie character that Marvel
almost seemed forced to introduce the
idea into comics and so in this instance
what a more the enchantress does is
actually use for powers to basically
bond Barbara Norris with the personality
of Brunhilde initially this was not
known instead
Brunhilde n-- actually exists as a
concept at this time instead it was just
barbara Norris becoming the character of
a Valkyrie and then basically being
given all the powers of Thor - the
hammer that he wields and like control
over lightning and so because of that in
this particular circumstance Valkyrie
helps to engineer the escape of the
defenders Amora The Enchantress makes
her escape she turns Black Knight to
stone which nobody cared about and then
ultimately the stories kind of continue
now going into the future of the
defenders line of comics in Marvel
Comics especially when it comes to you
know the character of Valkyrie a Steve
Englehart only ever really wrote like a
handful of issues he wrote issues 1
through 11 basically on the Avengers
side he wrote issues 105 through 135 and
so we saw some cool crossovers like the
Avengers defenders war but for the most
part the evolution of the character of
Valkyrie was almost non-existent outside
of the fact that she was just a really
cool member of the team and you know
Englehart geillis displays of what she
was capable of but with eagle heart
leaving and traveling over to DC just
kind of giving up the idea of writing
two titles at one time we ended up
seeing you know the titles taken over by
like Len Wein and Steve Gerber who was
basically ousted in 1978 after he tried
to sue Marvel for Howard the Duck we
ended up seeing things like Gerry Conway
taking over the title and all honesty
the character of Valkyrie just was a
character on the team that was really
about it
it wasn't until the publication was
taken over by David Anthony Kraft with
issue number 58 in 1978 that we began to
see this sort of wholesale reformation
of the Valkyrie concept and taking this
character who had just kind of been
created by a more of the enchantress and
actually creating roots and creating an
alternate personality and finally
establishing this sort of you know Thor
Donald Blake dichotomy with regards to
the Brunhilde Barbara Norris personality
beginning with issue number 58 and
running all the way up to issue number
68 what David Anthony crafts a really
David Kraft started doing was crafting
this sort of epic in the sense that
between issues 58 and 65 Valkyrie would
start to get these weird visions where
she would basically get these sort of
flashbacks quote-unquote to a life that
she doesn't recall as a result what
David Anthony crafts started doing was
basically revealing the idea that
Valkyrie was part of a group called the
Val Cure and what the Val QR did is they
were basically responsible for rescuing
the dead who who basically worship as
Guardians from the battlefield and
taking them directly to Valhalla
Valkyrie herself was the leader of the
value or she was the leader of this
group now this revelation came to a head
in issue 66 through 68 in a story titled
vow and Valhalla and it was basically
just this idea that Brunhilde was the
actual Valkyrie and Brunhilde existed in
the same body alongside Barbara Norse
and it allowed for this sort of Donald
Blake Thor dichotomy to exist for the
character of Valkyrie herself but for
quite some time
nothing was never really done about that
things largely just sort of remain the
same as they always had with the added
bonus the Valkyrie my crossover with
Thor that she would appear in other
titles outside of the defenders but
again that was really about it however
in 1981 with issue number 92 running all
the way through to 1984 with issue
number 118 writer J M DeMatteis had
taken over the defenders line and if the
blog of Jim shooter is to be believed
because he was editor-in-chief by
editorial decree Jim shooter wanted to
bring Valkyrie closer in line with the
Thor mythos by just making her the
character she was supposed to be and so
in defenders issue number 109 a story
called cry the Valkyrie Barbara Norrises
body was effectively killed and what
this did is it allowed Marvel to go
forward and basically take the character
of Brunhilde the actual Valkyrie and
give her her original body back and so
going forward into Marvel Comics
following the cry the Valkyrie story
Brunhilde and Valkyrie were the same
person who is basically her own body
it was tantamount to casting off the
Donald Lake personality and all you had
was Thor this coincided with the with
Thor issue number 337 about a year and a
half later when Walt Simonson took over
the Thor title and it allowed marwilt
across the characters over even more due
to the fact that the Thor mythos was
being expanded more than ever before by
Walt Simonson himself the downside to
this was that because Walt Simonson's
run on Thor was so well received
interest in Valkyrie effectively
plummeted in the eyes of a lot of people
who were reading the Thor comics they
effectively viewed Valkyrie is like a
poor man's Thor she was just a female
ripoff of Thor and so because of that
with the defenders title already a lean
due to the fact that the Silver Surfer
and Doctor Strange in the Incredible
Hulk they had effectively taken off and
they were replaced by characters like
Andromeda and manslaughter and candy
southern and interloper what it meant
was at the defenders line essentially
just flawed and so in February of 1986
with issue number 152 Jim shooter
ordered the title to be canceled and so
what happened was writer Peter B Gillis
basically followed up these last
vestiges of the plot threads and Doctor
Strange sorcerer supreme issues 3 & 4 by
basically saying that in this final
battle with the defenders and you know
this massive dragon you know this dragon
of the moon as it was called that
Valkyrie have her physical form had
basically died and instead what she had
done is her essence had gone back to
Asgard then reconstituted and then she
went back to being her wall as the
leader of the Valkyrie which is to say
taking this
of those who worship as Guardians uh who
died on the field of battle and taking
them to Valhalla and she basically
remained that way for over 20 years
between 1986 and 2004 Valkyrie was gone
from the Marvel landscape she had
disappeared in her entirety and even
then back in 2004 the only real
indication we saw of her existence was
the fact that she was one of the
Asgardians who had effectively died
during the events of Ragnarok when Loki
had marched on Asgard and basically
brought a crumbling down to the ground
now going into the post Ragnarok run of
J michael Straczynski and the return of
the Asgardians for most fans of Valkyrie
it was believed that this is where she
would make her return but instead she
didn't her character didn't actually pop
up until the Ed Brubaker written series
Secret Avengers and the whole idea was
that this basically came out of Dark
Reign this was essentially a set of
events where the Secret Invasion
storyline basically led to the idea that
the scrolls are replacing humans and
superheroes Tony Stark was ousted a
shield due to his failure to realize
this was happening Norman Osborn the
Green Goblin was put in charge of shield
he immediately dissolved shield form
hammer got rid of the superhuman
Registration Act from Civil War 1 and
then in turn was effectively defeated
and removed from the equation but during
the time in which he was running hammer
where he was basically running the show
while his schemes were pretty sinister
in the sense that he was intended to use
his power to plot world domination he
attached Captain America Steve Rogers
with carrying out his own goals or
carrying out his own actions in response
to this Steve Rogers formed a team
called The Secret Avengers and then
Valkyrie was just there she was just
suddenly part of the team there wasn't a
whole lot of explanation in terms of how
she got there it was just she was one of
the Asgardians who was resurrected after
the events of Ragnarok and that was
really about it but for most fans of
Valkyrie they didn't really care how it
was that she was there just so long as
she was there the downside to this was
that there wasn't really a whole lot
done with her character there was some
to a degree but it was really an attempt
by Marvel through various writers and
storylines the revamped fearless
defenders the idea of her playing a role
in fear itself and getting the hammers
of those who were chosen to be worthy by
the the serpent basically the secret
brother of Odin for the most part it was
those little stories here and there that
were designed to tap back into the old
Steve Gerber Steve Englehart jmd Mateus
David Kraft run on the Avengers and the
development of vaca Valkyrie but
ultimately it didn't really work and so
wouldn't it have had
is in the elicited bits of the fearless
defenders run one of the things that
Marvel did was introduce a character by
the name of Annabel Riggs and NFL Riggs
was basically this archaeologist that
was a huge fan of you know old artifacts
things like that but the idea here was
to take the character of Valkyrie and to
merge her with Annabel Riggs sort of
bringing back this old Brunhilde and
Barbara Norris concept and so what ended
up happening is during the final final
tidbits of this story Annabel Riggs was
effectively killed
Brunhilde to the afterlife alongside the
assistant of sorts of Doctor Strange
Clea and in turn had Annabel Riggs
resurrected but at the cost of that
Valkyrie spirit would be bonded to
Annabel Riggs for all time and so it was
basically this idea that Valkyrie would
be stuck to the character the problem is
that this happened anywhere around 2014
I think 2013 2014 and so this
effectively dead ended into Marvel's
start of the collapse of the multiverse
the Avengers and New Avengers written by
Jonathan Hickman and the Secret Wars
event in 2015 and so whatever intentions
Marvel had with the character of
Valkyrie were effectively shelved in
place of the collapse of the multiverse
in the launch of all-new all-different
marvel now as far as I'm aware Valkyrie
has not appeared an all-new
all-different marvel we don't know where
she is we don't even know if she exists
anymore most likely she was just
forgotten by Marvel editorial regardless
of the scenario Valkyries not there now
most likely in response to the thor
ragnarok film Valkyrie will make a
return and will most likely see this
sort of second iteration of the Lady
liberators essentially an all-female
superhero team but regardless hopefully
this video would help you guys
understand about the character of
Valkyrie she's a little wild she's a
little crazy or her history's a little
muddled but the fact remains here
basically imagine a female version of
Thor who's less powerful I mean honestly
the Valkyrie concept has been replaced
by Jane Foster
for the most part while Jane Foster is
Thor most likely you know if Marvel
makes the mistake which I think they're
gonna make they're probably just gonna
turn Jane Foster into Valkyrie which I
really hope they don't do she's an
amazing Thor regardless of how that
plays out Valkyrie may or may not return
I have no earthly clue in terms of what
will happen but well the current story
and Marvel legacy is the death of the
Mighty Thor but it doesn't mean that
Jane Foster will actually die it
probably just means that like Odin son
will get his hammer back and then
they'll probably turn her into Valkyrie
now that I think about it god I'd be so
disappointing because like nobody likes
Val but nonetheless hopefully this
helped to educate you guys have been
then be sure to hit the like button if
you are new here to comment explain make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core and I know I said
that outro out of order but I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]